كنت اهدف الي حقيقه هو ان نبتعد عن السجال
الديني عن تناول شخصيه معاويه بن ابي
سفيان رضي الله عنه بعيدا عن الجانب
الديني الذي يحدث في هذا السجال ونقدمه
بشخصيته البشريه الطبيعيه بمنجزاته
الحضاريه السياسيه هذا هو الهدف عكس تماما
ما ذكرت فاريد ان اذكر شخصيه معاويه بن
ابي سفيان ما هو اثرها الحضاري الثقافي
الاجتماعي الاقتصادي في تاريخنا هذا الاثر
كيف اثر على جميع الناس على جميع الطوائف
بكل اشكالهم والوانهم حتى الذي حتى
المختلفين معه هذا هو المقصود من هذا
المقال ولذلك حرصت في هذا الموضوع انا
اتحدث عن ما هو اثر ومنجزات معاويه بن ابي
سفيان في جانب السياسه في جانب الاقتصاد
في جانب تاسيس الدوله العربيه الاسلاميه
التي يعني اسست امبراطوريه كبرى في العالم
في ذلك الوقت وكانت الدوله الامويه
ومعاويه بدعم بسفيان هو احد من وضع ركائز
حقيقه النظام السياسي العربي الذي كل من
جاء بعده
استلهموا واستفادوا والتزموا بهذه الطريقه